hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm joined once again by my good
friend Bob hi how's it going Bob hey oh
really good this is the best experience
I've had in a long time playing I must
yeah you were on that PI population
server yes how that one for you God you
people horrible people
I got I loaded this up the other day
just for fun and I got on a server so it
was like hassles like maybe a hundred
people out of 250 or something I was
like oh I'll just jump on like hang
around see if any people got on I
literally like spawned was murdered
spawn somewhere else
instantly murdered that happened about
five or six times and I was just like
well I'm never playing this [ __ ] game
again well that's what you get for
trying to be friendly but trigger-happy
oh that guy's good that guy's amazing
I guess what was his channel too random
game a random gamer girl random gamer
anyway like comment and subscribe if you
think he was as nice it's nice up see
just you you be nice to d'marco boom he
good yeah don't you good good are we
regressing back to cavemen he goes oh my
god he gue hope more goo as him cuz if
he GU other B go to yeah right okay so
now in this adventure we're finally
cooking up some metal ore I'm about to
have enough to make a real metal hat put
more why would he want to metal hatchet
I mean a sword I don't know what else
can we make we can make a gun I have
some 9-millimeter have a gun can I make
a I well that's really nice for you I
have what get yes that's um that's hot I
I don't know a voice that was I guess
I'm Batman ever good I have I'm Batman
I'm Batman that's that's um Donnie Q at
hand cannon that's uh okay it's good as
a well I don't know what is a hand k to
do I don't know but it doesn't see an
unreliable shotgun type you that's it
the damage is ridiculous huh
hahahaha maybe it's good I'll just make
you a hunting bow Oh metal hatchet oh
okay I see what you're talking about
yeah I was gonna make like a nice
hatchet I'll make you I'll make you a
9-millimeter and I'm gonna make myself a
hatchet I'm gonna make myself some cloth
armor Booya
what's this I'm a fully clothed maniac
oh yeah yeah yeah look you're wearing
all white with a black turban II hat
thing I can't look but hey that's cool
too your your helmet is really strange
thank you the radiation helmets a rad
suit I got the rad boots the last time
we were playing but I never finished oh
yeah no I could probably go scavenge two
more but we'll wait relieved it's all
right I can finally stop using my
freakin gun Rock hey gun rock
oh yeah the gun rock I remember now
alright look at that I have a big boys
hatchet alright what was that nothing
probably who's out there
oh my god oh my god you have to chuck it
right okay all right should I just open
my door and blast my face I think he's
naked it's a person yet obviously the
person okay this is kind of fun I'm
gonna I'm gonna put my valuable stuff in
this box here and I'm gonna quickly open
my doors step out hang on hang on and
let me let's do that let's open both
doors at the same time and if he's on
your side you know retreat but if he's
on my side I'll blast him in the face
cuz I have a shotgun
hahahaha maybe hang on let me I um whoo
all right okay all right man I only have
a bow you have the freakin gun well let
me hang on can I make a pistol real
quick I think I can make a pistol I have
enough for a pistol yeah yeah I know I
haven't at all iiiiii oh I actually have
enough to make this why don't I make
look other wheels low quality metal oh
[ __ ] I don't have enough do we have any
9-millimeter am i do i do can you make a
pistol real quick
yeah like how there's just a guy outside
we're all quick would make this'll just
make a pic make this at least we're not
talking in chat we could all do you have
any more metal fragments as you take you
I took him out how many local email do
you have actually I am good I just need
to make one more low quality metal which
I can do right here I dropping it you
have it ready okay and then I will make
a 9 millimeter stola yeah yeah I don't
know why you're so ungrateful for your
hunting bow it's not bad but I mean I'd
rather have a gun just saying pistola
yes what do we need what we need for
ammo though you know I have ammo I put
it in the thing I have em okay okay you
ready ready for this huh yeah are you
ready I hear wait why I'm get out there
okay close your door close your damn
door
oh my god he killing how did he kill you
how did he kill you I ran out of ammo ah
he tried to shoot me he's got a bow I
ran out of ammo where's your stuff I got
it it's right here where is he he ran
over that way oh god oh god
scoodle humper [ __ ] no you didn't know
you didn't know no no no where'd he go
he went up into the mountains alright I
don't think we're gonna find him dude I
okay go back go back go back
I'm back huh I retreated almost
instantly you don't worry good I got
your back
how did it kill you though I don't know
he got like a head shot you got all your
stuff back though right yeah I got all
my stuff okay back in the house a little
bit bag yeah okay
brutal make hum provost like comment and
subscribe if you think he is the biggest
dick in the entirety of that oh I ran
out of it is that you are killed
hahahaha
that little douche prepare to die
that can you hear me typing furiously no
I can't
but type furiously you're dead you have
incurred the wrath of the entire
internet me may the inter but have mercy
on your soul maybe odds be ever in your
deathbed hahaha you typed that haha
that's what he gets
is that the real markiplier ha ha ha ha
ha I was yelling at him how does he not
know ok anyway know what's really funny
is if he watches your channel yeah he'll
find out that it was yeah
strudel become perfect you're the
biggest dick of the entirety of the
world we hope that you never ever have
any sort of success in your life there
you go told you muck skirm Lou you go
take that you'll go take that from this
douche i guy showed him I see him
he's over there he's just standing there
yeah there
hey where'd that gunpowder I had go Oh
is here it's just turning into now we
just kill that dude yeah now we just
kill that dude that's all this is No
okay charcoal ends this is our life now
yes he will die I'm going to make I need
to make 9-millimeter ammo which I can
make one of but I need more he let you
live before you moved in nearby we were
here long before you were ha ha ha ha
movie and now you will I feel like we're
sending really strange messages back and
forth kiss keys all I hate you guys
markiplier we're all just like joking
around I'm gonna murder your family huh
is that really him joking around when I
murder your family yeah when you die
it's going to be very slow and painful
this as soon as I play it makes you say
300 this isn't going to be pleasant
you're not going to enjoy this luckily I
forgot that I forgot that my name was
actually markiplier in this one cuz
usually it's something else so uh Oh
show me - now I have I have a shotgun
and it hatchet and we have some food
yeah now what do we do we kill that guy
that is our only purpose in life now
alright I'm gonna oh man I'm gonna make
myself a 9-millimeter pistol too then
hmm I don't have enough how much a
shotgun ammo do you have left uh 31
shells okay your please stick with the
shotgun I'm just gonna stick with the
pistol I have 17 bullets oh how do how
do we make more shotgun a movin I don't
know if you can I think you have to find
that hopefully in your video oh yes you
are
haha oh I think is it Han who was that
who was that who shooting who shootin uh
are we safe in here yeah I think so
I hope so like tirtha turn the fires off
and go into like stealth mode yeah do
that turn off you [ __ ] fire oh he's
coming around my side okay I hear two
sets of footprints hang on let me I've
got some valuable stuff in my inventory
let me get rid of this yeah let me drop
off - oh okay okay
what the hell not dead yet oh that
didn't kill us I like how it says we're
cold like I [ __ ] care
we're in DEFCON 3 hahaha
super secret stealth mode of murder so
do we like bust out and try and kill
this dude or no there's two sets of
footprints just there waiting for us we
just got out wait them
oh my god you want me to yell into the
microphone yeah always we hear you know
you're there go away it's our home well
good job with that we're not who I think
someone else wants to kill you too I
think someone else is trying to kill him
I wonder if I if what's-his-face came
back and it's defending a baby maybe
he's the coolest guy alive again what
was his user name the basket the game
did gamer a random gamer no I wasn't
there maybe it was it was da something
gamer I don't remember
maybe was the random but either way if
he's oh oh oooh I was like oh what
happened oh I guess if they know we're
in here we don't really have to be in
stealth mode we're not here go I know
one is home
yeah what he said who's not here who was
that it's a ghost hail a from these
ladies I don't do you fear death ah
cuz I'm David Jones ease down now oh
nothing whose ear is that her friend
that's our friend didn't know now it
might not be our friend we don't know
what did one give mark on his last
birthday day you'd know that if you
learn that guy who gave us this thing
who's that hey dildo that's not him he
deserved to die
it does kind of sound like who's there
no it's not him I actually know how stay
at sturdy this house is gold I like need
my bra I'll feel something mouth Oh easy
mark well there really never been a
social harassment lawsuit from a video
game button I want it back really
Rudolph decided or no
I'll let you guys live if you do what
who says you can kill us exactly
hahahahaha you can't simple wooden plank
plank you stand no chance yeah all of
your bullets and all of your things
cannot open my heart of man keyboard
well do it do I actually have c4 alert
man do it come on do it do it [ __ ] he
did it didn't hurt me oh my god what
happened hey get it get back in there
junkies will take you can do with that
shotgun dude ah kill you kill me yeah
pretty much
well well alright I will thwart him with
my yodeling skills you just heard the
battle song of Mario buyer and now you
shall be purged
ah are you frightened you feel a chill
down your spine
don't go taik to me yes you'll be
banished to the third Bobby don't
Rober doing the plan you sneaking around
I am right keep distracting him keep
screaming I'm gonna sneak out the back
and try and kill him okay oh my god oh
my God look at that
what happened Bob I'm out here I moved
into our secret camp okay so I'm kind of
hiding from him keep messing should I
keep the campfire on in here yeah go for
it
how you doing Bob
I'm fine finally get really far away oh
my god there's sky on top
oh is it two against two yeah okay I
don't know how what should I do
um I don't know I don't think we planned
this very well like in the house can you
get back in probably life now is this
just the whole thing I don't know I
don't know anymore
how do we make peace with these people
okay I don't know we don't go right over
there wait Han hey tell us your names
type in chat I want to talk with you
guys no no I mean seriously you're gonna
be watched by hundreds of thousands of
people could be good for you if you want
no do you not know our YouTube channel
three million subs pretty good for you
mm-hmm do you want some publicity and
maybe I thought so yeah type you're
wrong if you got anything you want
promote typing in chat right now I don't
know if he's falling for it no he's not
falling for it ah that's me that's you
okay everyone in the comments below say
how much games all day 50 is the worst
person in the world
big giant stupid ha ha ha ha ha ha ok ha
ha ha ha
big dumb stupid head big job stupid head
ok anyway thank you we're actually we're
actually it was weird woah oh my god ha
ha that was a mistake
kind of ok do it so anyway alright
alright that'll be the end of this
episode turn on the lights it's dark in
here almost it's almost night out there
it's almost day anyway so anyway this
has been fun for this one we're gonna
cut it here but anyway this has been fun
right wait right Bob yeah anyways yeah
it's been fun
thanks Wade your though I'm way now fast
okay so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation with more
videos that I've done and hopefully you
just understand this is all in fun we're
not really big E's the worst would never
even though he is kinda a little bit
okay Hannah bean I know II kind of being
a little bit anyway thank you all so
much for watching blah blah blah thanks
Bob for joining me and as always we'll
see you in the next video
musics good it was the sound okay zom
zoms here this way
okay so what do we do what the hell are
we gonna do I don't know ha
let's see we could go out guns blazing I
got a lot of armor on my stuff I don't
have anything I just don't know where he
is
does the broad I've almost on our roof I
they built like a ramp or something onto
the roof so wait they're above us right
now well he was shooting at me from the
roof when I snuck over to the other camp
yeah oh hello oh my gosh mark yeah we're
gonna die yeah probably
cook we should just can we come up with
some sort of ridiculous premise and like
do a bottle episode where we're just in
here the whole time next time and I
don't know I don't know if we have to
like acting wherewithal to actually make
that funny but oh yes we do are you
kidding me we could make it SuperDuper
funny let me just get more ammo though
cuz I know I can I can just and we'll
end it with like us going guns blazing
it'll be totally awesome oh my god I
hope they just leave and we spend the
whole time and then we just go out there
and they're gone I wouldn't count on it
but you never know could be never up
okay how much bullets do I have
I can make 16 more bullets okay okay